[Musique]
monsieur la famille c'est vrai ce qu'on
dit sur moi ni personne vous êtes le
meilleur des gardes du corps
faux pouvait tirer si bâle au même
endroit
[Musique]
pop up
mon père était scientifique il a créé un
sérum d'amour
rendre irrésistible celui qu'il utilise
ce parfum à l'odeur roach et celui qui
le respirons une explosion de
l'attirance émotionnel c'est n'importe
quoi c'est parfois mes gènes ont senti
ça marche je change de sexe pour un plus
grand
vraiment
il reste combien temps pour retrouver la
mallette 47 eur qu'est ce que vous
foutez là vous gêne est venu vous ai dit
car mes vêtements quand les
[Musique]
non
c'est lourd
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais